every autumn herds of reindeer are
driven down the yamal peninsula in
russia's arctic north
the herders are members of the nenets
people who have traditionally led
nomadic lives
they cross the frozen ob river which is
several kilometers wide at this point
at night and with great caution
climate change is making the ice thinner
by the year
at night when it's colder there's less
risk of it breaking
this group reaches the far shore at
daybreak
they're accompanied by anthropologist
alexander volkowitzki
who's been studying the life and customs
of the nets people for many years
for those nomadic families living in
tundra
the main problem is the condition of
their heads
because they depend from their reindeer
and
their future means a good condition of
their head
that future is anything but secure the
arctic has been warming at about twice
the rate of the planet as a whole
for the net herders it's becoming more
and more difficult to travel their
traditional routes
ice forms on the rivers ever later in
the season
forcing the families and herds to wait
lots of families have no way out there
is no possibility for them to move
it's a threatening situation for all the
northern reindeer herding way of life so
to say
the reindeer need to keep moving in any
one spot there's not much to eat
and they would quickly starve to death
so the herders need to move with them
two and a half thousand kilometers to
the east in yakutsk
the capital of the republic of sakha
also known as yakutia
yego kirillin is on his way to the
institute for biological problems
of the cryolithozone that's the region
where permafrost prevails
he's a biologist and studies wild
reindeer whose numbers are declining
the head of the institute in
kentiaglobkov is
there used to be more than a million
reindeer
the two biologists say climate change
but also human interventions
are behind the steep decline in numbers
one growing problem is competition
between wild reindeer and herded
reindeer
kudelin is on an expedition on the
eleniak river
which cuts through one of the main
routes of migrating wild reindeer
in order to find out more about their
migration patterns
he wants to attach transmitter collars
to as many specimens as he can catch
the devices have been adapted to the
conditions here in yakutia
they're waterproof
and they can withstand temperatures of
minus 40 to minus 50 degrees celsius
the team have to be patient they're
watching out for any reindeer swimming
across the river
when they spot one they have to act fast
[Music]
this young male probably weighs more
than 130 kilograms
the procedure can be dangerous for the
men and is probably a bit of a shock for
the reindeer
the transmitter is designed to fall off
once the battery is empty
they take the animal's portrait for the
database and let him go
they've attached such devices to more
than 40 wild reindeer so far
the data have already revealed that
migration patterns are changing
the reindeer head north to cooler summer
pastures earlier in the season every
year
and in the winter they head deeper into
the more southerly forests
to find enough to eat and that's where
the competition with domesticated ones
is growing
wild reindeer have always been seen as
rivals of domesticated herds
it's impossible to breed them where
there are lots of wild ones
where there are both populations herding
is hard domesticated reindeer often run
away and join the wild ones
and they compete for grazing
food is becoming scarcer even in the
vast and undeveloped far north of russia
based on data from the tracking devices
strategies could be developed to
mitigate competition among the diverse
populations
to benefit all of them but the changing
climatic conditions are also a challenge
in particular the rising temperatures
the herder families and their reindeer
continue their trek south
to their winter quarters in the forests
they still have
a long way to go as conditions change
the risks they face are changing too and
the pressure to adapt is mounting
the very future of their way of life is
at stake
you